the Museum of decorative arts located in
the lubies western wing is currently
hosting a show featuring l1 and Honan
Bullock it's called mo montenay which
translates as fleeting moments the
brothers inspect the arrangement some
fixed I Mon plaisir llamando no longer
gives me lots of pleasure and at the
same time it terrifies me but it's in
Sofia it's a great opportunity and but
I'm not much more self-confident as a
result Telmo super buu KU precio de moi
I'm completely I'm Fatima shows up it's
a chance for us to show our stuff to
people who may not specialists he calls
but are actually the ones who the work
is meant for it look I'm only later on
they did not provide the show covers
about 1,000 square meters in the museum
and will last six weeks volak brothers
also had a say in how their work is
displayed 15 years worth of their work
is here from tableware designed for
alessi
to the famous quilt sofa and this 12
meter tall 3d wall citic sweet soy sauce
exhibition plays on contrasts for
example we created this wall curtain for
the Danish firma quad it's very
technical and industrial yet delicate we
set it against a rug woven in Pakistan
using ancient techniques barely changed
over the centuries in approval ridicula
whether a limited edition or
mass-produced items the approach is the
same compose a listener compucom on
salvia when we've sketched out the
process it starts to take on a life of
its own we know that bit by bit we'll
have to reduce its elements the objects
are made a very little material and they
have a mineral peppered form rimini mama
nature has inspired some of their most
famous creations including the vegetal
chair and these algae inspired elements
for vitra which were featured at the
Museum of Modern Art in New York a vamp
or giant a toque el paso Enquirer gonna
be listening we already had this project
in mind don't coffee but nobody else
really believed in it once the sketches
were done it we arranged an exhibition
in Cologne por amor we used the budget
for the exhibition to produce the
prototypes for algae elements getting
their small parts that you can join
together to form a partition can assist
and about how it's our most successful
product with more than 8 million so so
far not people ship sailing down the
normal person okay papyri million case
quantify okay the brothers have about 20
projects going on at the same time in
their paris studio the two siblings
don't always see eye to eye but their
intensive collaboration generally
generates an innovative product
the first said la corporacion sometimes
we have a collaboration sometimes a real
confrontation okay but i think our
approach allows us to contemplate a
project from the inside and outside both
do all the project and to talk it over
together I'm on discute a ido question
el padre french journalist michelle
chinois and the show's curator Dominic
Bowie have followed the Bullock brothers
from the start they're not surprised
that their careers have gone
international situated on folks I their
strength lies in their remaining true to
themselves in preserving their own style
but still following all the dictates of
commercialism ok so far as a victim
their creations are modern and topical
nagaland a these systems for dividing up
space our response to our current
problems i bought these two apartments
that are too small for instance home for
good team now the talented designer
brothers can pick and choose their jobs
they enjoy taking on new and different
challenges
I tell more listen reduced hold on right
now we're at work on a chandelier for
the foyer of the Palace of Versailles
that's Daniel it's going to be installed
in November and will keep the palace
continually lit up a little young and
we've just completed some furniture for
the University of copenhagen's new
building here furniture for the students
to use what is it you jobs enfermo y Moi
dreams of designing a sailboat someday
maybe even as his next project but the
current exhibition will be running
through early September at the Louvre